[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Kate how
can we
help hi thanks for taking my call how
are you doing well we're having a blast
what can we help you
with um I feel like I'm a lost cause and
I'm possibly stuck where I'm at and what
I'm doing well let me start by saying
number one you are not a lost cause and
you are not stuck my guess is you've
choosen to stay put because of fear and
doubt how about
that well I've been let down a lot when
um I'll bet I was debt free at one point
yeah a few times actually 100% like my
phone or not my phone hello sorry my car
my student loan and everything credit
cards were all paid off I'm good to go I
had cash to my name and I tried to get a
house and all I heard was no and no and
no and I'm a single
parent of two kids and
it's extremely hard to
um get out of subsidized housing I've
been in for 10 years about and I'm tired
of having to tell them when I get more
money when I don't get more money and
just the fluctuation the paperwork and
it's already hard two kids yeah on my
own and no dad's to help so I'm sorry
well George and I are gonna we're g to
help I only work parttime as a perero in
a school for 16 an
hour and I feel like I really want to
work full-time I know you do and I have
and I really want to you know bust it
out and break free of this feel like a
cell in my heart and in my home I want
to get somewhere and I feel like I'm
just no one knows anything in my family
about money
and I feel like all I knew was saving
and debt and I never knew about all this
other stuff until I watched days up the
screw to people well listen which is
nice because like I need that kick in
the pants too yeah well let me tell you
what you need you need some confidence
because I I believe that you have what
it takes to repeat the process of
getting out of debt you've done it
before so I know you can do it again I
also know that you're you're up against
it right now because you're just simply
not bringing in enough
income no and I mean if you were
bringing in more income now but I'm
afraid if I get out of here how am I
going to make it well so
income okay income and a budget all
right so let's talk about the income
piece for a second all right so what
would you need to make financially to be
able to get out of subsidized housing
and get a decent place to rent for you
and the kiddos what's that
number
oh I honestly don't know okay what's
keeping you what's keep is so low right
now it's like 107 for my rent but that's
feasible but regular rent around here
it's anywhere between 1,200 and 1500 May
Kate Kate all right you gotta listen now
okay you're making a lot of excuses and
I know you've been through a lot I know
we can't make any more excuses so you
said you need somebody to kind of give
you a little kick in the pants and I'm
going to do that as gently as I can
George is a lot nicer than I am but I'm
going to be nice I'm good cop he's bad
cop okay no but listen we got a number
now let's take the highest number just
because it's going to help us George and
I going to do this together okay now
okay George is gonna help out on the
budgeting and all that kind of stuff
second but I want to get this income F
Factor figured out all right so let's
say $1,500 a month is something that
that gets us a nice place to live and oh
my gosh how happy would you be if you
could easily afford a12 to $1,500
apartment how happy would you you be
Kate tell
me I honestly don't want to be in any
apartment anymore though okay where do
you want where do you want Kate stop
take the big leap getting a house Kate
we got to take a baby step for now Kate
you've never played basketball and you
want a dunk it doesn't work that
way stop that right now stop
that okay an apartment that is not
government subsidized housing is the
next goal yes or
no you better say yes yes you're only
working okay here's the deal Kate you're
only working part-time as a parpro in a
school making $16 an hour you are not
making enough money you are a mama bear
who has gotten put in a tough situation
because of deadbeat dads these guys if
they were in this studio right now i'
I'd get after him with a whiffle ball
bat because I couldn't hurt him bad
enough to really put him in the hospital
but I'd sting them good they're jerks
they're low lives they're lazy they're
punks all the words that I can say on
the air and I understand that and it
sucks but you're the mama bear and you
got to take care of those kiddos and you
are worth way more than $16 an hour so
you got to go work at Walmart or Kroger
or somewhere or Target where they're
paying a lot more than $16 an hour
they're paying health care benefits they
will even pay for your college educ
Walmart has made this a national program
Kate I'm giving you one
idea I just got out of Walmart I don't
care go
back no $20 it was 14 and that was still
part-time and I had to be there one day
weekend and I have no sitter to watch
you got to find somebody you got to find
an old lady who goes to a church that
you go to you've got to stop making
excuses and you've got to start making
things happen so income is is what you
have got to do you have got to make more
money if it's two jobs three jobs and we
find somebody to watch the kiddos you
can find a way and then George what do
she got to do with that money well we're
going to put it to use in our budget
Kate and I'm going to throw some things
at you we're going to gift you some
stuff to help you take that right Next
Step because we only have a minute here
on the air but how much debt do you
have I am whittling my last um or I'm
plastic surgery my last discover card at
about
$4,900 okay so once the $44,900 credit
card bill is gone you're completely Deb
free completely yet again do you have
any money in the bank problem with
gambling and drinking I have two
addictions as well which I've been you
seeking counseling and help for that yes
I am okay good so we're going to get you
on some good footing on that side on top
of getting you out of debt do you have
any money in the
bank uh I keep that very minuscule so B
basically no just enough for my bills so
I don't go and use my debit card for
purchases I don't need to okay that's
good well what I'm going to do is I'm
going to set you up with one of our
Ramsay Financial coaches on our team and
I'm going to gift that session to you so
they can take some time pour into the
details and walk you through this on top
of that I'm going to gift you one year
of every dollar premium I'm going to
gift you Financial Peace University
watch all of those nine lessons begin to
make a budget even if you don't have a
lot of income make the budget income
than your expenses then we know what the
Gap is then we can see what we need to
do to get out of this debt to build the
emergency fund get on our feet increase
our income like Ken said and get out of
this cycle we believe you can do it
there's nothing that a mama bear
wouldn't do for a kiddos and you're
going to have to choose those kiddos
right now and you're going to have to
work like you've never worked before in
your life is it going to be really hard
yes is it doable yes are you the only
single mom to ever have to do it no you
got to choose today's the day to choose
your babies and their future create your
free every dooll budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life